so i'm going to be talking about rails
challenges um this is a warm-up act for
a much more conceptual in-depth brain
stimulating talk this is a little bit
more about
psychology rather than engineering
here's the
url for the slideshow
and uh if anybody's got hacker news
karma points they want to gain go ahead
post it because it hasn't been posted
anywhere yet and this is a good
controversial kind of uh um
a discussion that um people on reddit
and hacker news like to engage in um
so why should and i'll talk
in a minute about the fluffy cat but why
should we be trying to help out rails
beginners i think it's because all of us
are working in places either we're in a
startup that's desperately trying to
recruit more engineering talent or we're
on a team where if we just had a few
more senior level developers maybe we
could move a little faster maybe the
workload wouldn't be as killer so it's
up to us to try to bring those rails
beginners up to speed because if we need
more senior developers we need more
junior developers and to have more
junior developers we need to help
beginners get ramped up from html and
css to web applications two years ago
most of the people getting on board with
rails
most of you probably here in this room
already had experience as web
application developers already came from
a background of java or php already knew
some of the con
concepts and the principles of building
a web application but something has
changed in the last maybe two years or
so people want to do web development
instead of thinking about learning to
use wordpress or a little php or
studying a little javascript
they're saying hey i've got to learn
this ruby on rails thing even if they
don't know what it is
so we're seeing a lot more people coming
into the community as absolute beginners
and to accommodate that we've got some
really really great books out there you
know books by ryan biggs michael
hartle's tutorial are things we probably
all recommend something that i learned
from probably many of you learned from
but it's still really gauged at an
intermediate level not absolute
beginners some assumptions are made so i
wanted to help out those beginners so i
just finished writing a book it's
just launching now with a kickstarter
campaign if you want to contribute to
getting it off the ground
and it's aimed at absolute beginners to
introduce them to rails but in a way
that introduces some real professional
practices
so in writing the book
i had
hundreds of people user testing it and
giving me feedback and i encountered a
lot of challenges that people ran into
as rails beginners
so
rails is getting more complicated um you
know we may have gained mastery over the
last few years and you know we struggle
a little bit keep up rails four is out
what strong parameters you know what are
concerns whatever but imagine a beginner
rails just keeps getting more uh
innovation more powerful turbo links
asset pipeline all the stuff is coming
on board and there's just that much more
to learn as mentors really it's up to us
to help how else are are people going to
get up to speed with rails so what are
some of the strategies we can help
beginners with um
think about the
psychological phenomena of resistance
when you start to feel overwhelmed when
you're tired and discouraged when you've
been banging your head all day trying to
figure out some code
things
small hills start to become mountains
little issues start to be really big
issues this is a familiar feeling for
anybody imagine what it's like to be a
beginner and encountering rails for the
first time and not having had the
satisfaction of building something
seeing something work and encountering
some initial challenges suddenly those
challenges get really big people are
ready to quit people you know
the resistance the psychological
phenomena begins to attach both to two
categories of problems both to imaginary
problems and to real proud problems
imaginary problems are problems like oh
my god you know i'm not smart enough to
do this web development stuff i'm not
smart enough to learn rails i should
have had a
maybe a computer science background in
school or those of you who do have a cs
background you may be thinking i
shouldn't have wasted four years in cs
how am i going to learn this stuff
so those are imaginary problems they
just get blown up big out of proportion
the the problems that that we can deal
with as mentors are the real problems
because there are some real challenges
to rails some genuine challenges um and
when the resistance attaches to those
real problems we need a strategy for
coping with that
so how do you overcome resistance first
of all
acknowledge that there is a real problem
it doesn't make rails bad it doesn't
make rails inferior it just means that
we have to recognize that there are some
speed bumps some hurdles
and as a mentor helping out a beginner
help them scale down the magnitude of
the problem so instead of uh the
mountain let's get it back to the size
of molehill let's recognize and support
that yes you may be encountering real
challenges but
um we can solve those problems um
everybody has there are
thousands tens of thousands now of rails
developers who have overcome these
problems so how do we go about doing
those as mentors
probably not a good idea to simply solve
the problem for a person don't just grab
their keyboard and start typing in the
code that they need instead you know
help them out with some resources help
them out with some problem solving
approaches and so for this talk here for
the next 15 or 20 minutes let's go
through kind of a process of
encountering some typical rails
challenges some of them that have come
up with the real beginners that i've
worked with and let's as an exercise
think of some of the ways we could
approach those problems scale them down
to uh scale down the magnitude of the
problem
challenge number one it's difficult to
install ruby i mean we forget this
right we've all got ruby we've all got
rails up and running we've been running
it for months or years or whatever but
it is the beginner's first big obstacle
and
it's a significant obstacle for somebody
who hasn't done software development
before for somebody who's only you know
installed consumer apps this is nothing
like they've encountered before this is
not just um you know a drag and drop
point and click install um they're
dealing with system software for the
first time in their lives perhaps
and compounding the problem of course we
all know this every system is unique
every system is different some of you
may have um participated in railsbridge
work workshops and friday night they do
an install fest where everybody comes
and makes sure their computer is set up
before they try um actually
participating in the workshop the next
day and that install fest can go on for
hours and it's not just people running
on windows which i'll talk about in a
minute but it can be older versions of
macs that people haven't you know
updated the os from you know 10.5 and
suddenly they realize that they need all
these extra
things installed or maybe they installed
some other software and there's some
conflicts so those are real problems to
encounter how do we go about solving
those problems
well we've got a couple of approaches
that have worked in the past and as a
community we're getting better at it
we do have some attempts at building
point and click
single install
click
applications for installing the system
software for example
rails installer has been popular up
until maybe the last few months that was
a package that you could
install on windows or on mac and have a
whole
rails ruby and rails
development environment set up couple of
problems with rails installer that we
don't have time to look at right now it
can create conflicts down the road it
has there's a lot of magic involved
yehuda katz has been working on a
project called takaido which is a
sandboxed development environment that
you can simply install on your mac as a
point and click uh consumer type
application not quite ready for prime
time
um but in the last six months michael
pappas in poland has been working hard
on rvm to make that very much a single
uh single click installer for uh ruby
and rails rvm the ruby version manager
now i don't want to take sides there's a
people here who like using rbnv sam
stevenson's project
ch ruby these are all excellent tools
that we as experienced developers use to
switch back and forth between versions
of ruby and rails i particularly
recommend rvm though to beginners
because it uniquely has this ability to
do a point-and-click install where
system software that's needed on your
machine gets automatically installed to
the extent that it's possible so as
mentors we need to be aware of
some of the current practices that are
going to help beginners get up to speed
if nothing else works i really like
a new service called nitrous.io it's a
hosted development environment in the
cloud basically you sign up and you get
within your web browser complete uh
development environment with ruby and
rails pre-installed so if you're helping
out a beginner they can't figure out how
to get started um they're having
problems
and you can't figure out how to sort out
that issue just point them at nitrous
dot io i've got an article installing
rails too
that'll help um challenge number two
rails is a nightmare on windows anybody
here doing rails development on windows
started
what was that
that's the answer run a linux vm and i'm
sorry to say so here's the exercise
so many people use windows so many
people the only laptop they've got is a
windows machine they want to do ruby on
rails they come to you as a mentor a
friend or something like that
and you're like forget it you're not
gonna it's not gonna succeed on windows
you're you're you're gonna try to
installing gems and they won't work
so how do you deal with that they're
just gonna say well why that's not fair
you guys are so biased against windows
well let's deal with it there the bias
is there but it's not simply prejudice
it's because
um rails comes out of an open source
environment and most open source
developers use unix-based tooling it's a
historic historical accident it isn't
really any you know dislike for bill
gates or the evil microsoft empire it's
simply the fact that our environment has
built been built up using unix-based
tooling except that
not such a big problem because you can
do rails development if you've got a
windows laptop but you'll have to do
something like install a linux virtual
machine
you can use
again i mentioned nitrous io i like that
because there's nothing to install you
simply sign up for an account it's free
for ordinary you know small scale rails
development and you've got a full-blown
linux environment in your web browser or
download a vagrant virtual machine rails
bridge virtual machine is a good one
there's one called rails dev box
you can do
development on windows but as a mentor
you've got to help people out on that
one so
other typical
now i call them rails challenges but
they could also be called rails
complaints it's the things you hear when
people are like frustrated and they're
thinking you know maybe i should just
try going back to php or something like
that or maybe this is too hard
rails air reporting is cryptic
is it the stack traces are intimidating
the error messages are too technical why
can't it be simpler well how as mentors
do we help them deal with that
probably by acknowledging that yeah it
is intimidating but actually
rails error reporting is is actually
very good it provides all the details
that an experienced developer
needs to solve a particular problem
of course on the computer the computer
can't say what you did wrong the
computer can only tell you what happened
when you did it when the error happened
so there is an inherent limitation there
but simply acknowledging that as a fact
may help a beginner get over that hurdle
help them read the stack traces point
out that it's the first line in the
stack trace or the second line in the
stack trace that contains the error
message that you need to cut and paste
and google or look on stack overflow
stuff we all take for granted of course
but think about it from a beginner's
standpoint what would really be the most
helpful thing that we could do to get
them up to speed
rails challenge number four there's too
much magic now this is an interesting
one our convention over configuration
leads to some obscurity um
implementation often hidden deep in the
depths of rails now when you encounter
this rails complaint
um you've probably got somebody who in
the future may be a senior developer
that you want to work with because this
is the rails challenge that trips up the
clever ones it trips up the smart ones
particularly it trips up the people who
really want to know
how do things work
because they're playing with rails and
they're building a controller and
they're starting to scratch their head
and wondering okay i've got this action
in the controller well how how does
where does that view come from i don't
see the code that produces that view
well we probably don't think about it
anymore we simply accept the convention
that's there but if you wanted to
explain it you could point out well
actually there's some hidden code that
we don't see there's a rails keyword
called render which by convention
doesn't appear in the controller
controller actions but it's there and
you could actually type it in and show
it show them how it works you could
actually show that there's additional uh
parameters that you can pass to a render
keyword that you know renders without a
layout for example
um so you could help them dig into the
source code if they're really really
interested
maybe as an exercise in how to begin to
read source code or suggest that they
just take on faith that it works because
really isn't that what we all do i mean
how much time do we actually spend
digging in to see how render actually
works in rails we probably don't it's
nice exercise to uh to dig into the
source code sometime and take a look at
it but after a while we just take on
faith that it works so
along the same lines challenge number
five rails contains a lot of things i
don't understand so many files and
folders if you look in the rails
directory structure code that's
unfamiliar
um
the big question what parts do i need to
know
as
mentors we can say you know you'll gain
your understanding over time you don't
need to know all of rails to work with
rails to build applications and as
experienced developers we're always
learning there's aspects of rails that
you know that are still new to me that
i'm exploring there's aspects of rails
that have just been introduced that i
don't know anything about concerns maybe
i'll skip that one entirely based on the
advice given here um
so
help out the beginners by assuring them
that it's okay not to know everything
about rails there's too much to learn
well we all encounter that web
development used to be a lot simpler i
remember when we started out it was just
html and perl was all we needed to learn
but now wow javascript javascript
frameworks
of course databases sql oh nosql
and the list goes on doesn't it on and
on and on if you want to be a full stack
developer yeah let's get familiar with
all of that as a beginner should at
least have some sense of of of where the
different pieces fit in and what you use
to do what but um you know the reality
is um
we can't know it all and
one of the positive things
um there's joy in learning i mean that's
why we choose this profession in this
field often there's lots of great
resources we didn't have before back in
the days when it was just html and pearl
there wasn't any uh anything online
there wasn't code school rails for
zombies
um
you know tutorials um treehouse all
these uh um all these resources that we
now have available to learn so we can
keep up we they're structured learning
there's more attention to pedagogy and
how we learn
certainly your career will never be dull
and you can specialize that certainly
helps people realize that they don't
have to learn it all front end back end
you know what floats your boat
um
challenge seven
it's difficult to find up-to-date advice
isn't that true we've got new major
releases of rails every 1.5 to 3 years
two years on the average
if you're using google or stack over
clove to look for answers to problems
that you've encountered
that advice is going to be out of date
so
what can you do as a mentor show the
beginners how to evaluate advice
now
again this is intuitive for us but
you know
we're we're probably aware that when you
do a google search there's a little
search tools menu that drops down you
could filter by date
probably not everybody here uses that
but you know just being aware of that
and pointing that out to a beginner to
show them
you can filter out so you can only see
search results from say the last year
stack overflow doesn't have any feature
like that but show beginners how to
check the dates in stack overflow show
them how you go about interpreting a
stack overflow answer to evaluate which
of those it isn't necessarily the one
with the big green check mark next to it
uh it isn't necessarily the one with the
most up votes show them how you look at
it checking the date
evaluating those answers to see which
ones have
which of those answers has the greatest
relevance to to you
how you can follow a chain of other
stack overflow answers the related
questions related answers sometimes can
be very useful
um challenge number eight what gems to
use i mean gems is where we get most of
the power of rails is why we grow so
fast and have built so much momentum as
a community but how do you find the gems
to use
which gems are the best you know what do
you want to use for paginate what do you
want to use for authentication
gem discovery is an art
we can share that with beginners we can
acknowledge that there is no perfect
solution for finding gems
ruby toolbox is great most people here
are probably familiar probably have seen
it you know it's a great project to
catalog and rate
every gem out there but
it's maybe not possible to rate and
catalog every gem it's certainly a big
problem to solve the
the christopher who's been working on
that ruby toolbox project
struggles to maintain that site so it's
imperfect personally i tend to spend
get my clues about gems from example
applications i can encourage
uh beginners to look for example
application starter applications not
just the ones from the rails apps
project but
the consulting companies thoughtbot for
example has got some great
starter apps that you can look see what
you know what are these um
leaders in the community using as their
favorite gems
and certainly um you know point out to
beginners how important it is to keep up
with the community follow peter cooper's
excellent ruby weekly
email newsletter um peter cooper's ruby
flow daily um blog aggregator's site
it's you know definitely you know you've
got to spend your time
um keeping up with what's going on the
community to see you know what are the
gems
first of all they're being introduced
but also that other people are talking
about is useful
challenge number nine um
significant one when you get past the
tutorial stage how do you transition
from just following tutorials to
building your own applications a
question that beginners you know come
even coming out of dev boot camp or an
app academy you know we'll be
encountering as issues you know copying
and pasting uh gets me started but how
do i build an application from scratch
and here's where as mentors as
experienced developers you can really
help people focus on the process um you
know maybe we've got particular software
development methodologies that we're
using at work we don't have to try to
explain you know all the aspects of
agile or somebody something like that to
you know a friend who's just you know
trying to put a website together for
their you know club or
football team or something like that but
um introduce them to concepts like user
stories a great way to break down
into discrete units you know what your
application is going to do
suggest that they look for code samples
and just maybe implement spikes little
pieces of the application to begin
to begin finding things that work and
begin finding their you know finding the
getting grounded um with doing
development on their own
um questions come up like
challenge 10 i'm not sure where the code
goes
well does this code go in the model or
in the controller and
you know automatically we know where it
should go we've been doing it for months
or years or whatever but actually if you
think about it from the standpoint of a
beginner there's no you know you could
you can process you know what's coming
in input from a form or something in the
controller or or in the model um or
you know other places as well certainly
um
questions like well what if one of my
controller actions isn't restful how
much do i have to keep to that rest
model and does it fit or or not am i in
trouble if it doesn't um
so rather than directly answer those
questions here you know with mantras
like
you know skinny controller fat model or
you know more sophisticated
suggestions that you know even the model
can be thinned down and code moved to
the lib
folder
just point out the importance of getting
peer support um reading the blogs um
studying example apps and go to hack
nights
adrian
people here that i recognize from
that great hack night that they run over
at carbon 5
once a month on wednesdays
ask for code review get people to help
you out start pair programming
so those are 10 rails challenges i'm
going to throw out an 11th bonus one
that really doesn't fit
uh it's not really a problem that has
anything intrinsic intrinsically to do
with rails instead it has something to
do with our you know our social
structure and the environment we we're
in which is that um for some people
coming into learning rails there is this
challenge if people like me don't go
into programming
not every programmer looks like one
though i look around this room now and i
don't know that i can stereotype what a
typical programmer looks like um
actually brings great deal of joy to me
to see the range of of uh
of um different
uh faces and looks that we have here not
everyone has the same background um and
recognize
uh if if you know if you haven't already
that being different sometimes can be
challenging sometimes uh it can involve
self-doubt if you don't see people who
are
like you doing the thing you want to do
you wonder especially we're talking
about that phenomenon of
resistance when those mole hills turn
into mountains when resistance attaches
to imaginary problems you know that's
when the questions come up like well
maybe somebody like me shouldn't be
doing programming because i didn't have
a computer science background or
whatever you know
so
we can be more welcoming as a community
and it's not about because this is
something you know you'll see on
reddit or hacker news uh you know that
brings out the trolls somebody posts
something about a rails girls workshop
or something like that and suddenly
people are saying well well why do women
get special privileges and get to go to
workshops for free and the trolling goes
back and forth and back and forth but
it's not really an ideological problem
it's not really an issue of values
though you certainly can look at that at
it that way and debate it
as engineers i think we simply should
optimize for inclusion
companies that have a diverse workplace
tend to be more profitable tend to be
more successful um
we're not having to talk about diversity
here in the workplace so we don't need
to go into why that might be it's a it's
a fact um as
developers we tend to be curious we like
to do travel to foreign places meet
different people same thing it's kind of
fun to have a range of people in the
workplace who have different backgrounds
to encounter to hear their stories their
life stories the kind of problems
they've dealt with
so that's um
just all reasons that as engineers we
should find ways to make our workplaces
more inclusive and include those people
who may be feeling
i'm not sure i really belong here as a
developer because that's a challenge
that we certainly can overcome
again
i like to mention railsbridge and rails
girls because there are organizations
that do workshops here locally that
bring in more people for diversity in
our workplace workplaces um so
that's all i'm going to talk about and
if you want to discuss did anybody post
this to reddit or hacker news i don't
know
if it's there but if it's there that's a
good place to discuss it if it ended up
posting and um
i will get together with
joel and track down the first three
phone numbers that he got and connect
with you so you can have a hat
and um please
keep in mind that um
this is a chapter that's
excerpted from my new book and hopefully
that book will help beginners get up to
speed as well thanks very much i'm glad
i was able to be here with you